[Music]
on this Sunday night no solution and no
end inside the Israeli Prime Minister's
refusal of a two-state solution draws
International condemnation the right of
the Palestinian people to build their
own states must be recognized by all it
comes as the death toll in Gaza reaches
a new high and Palestinians face a
worsening crisis is Russia or Ukraine to
blame for deadly strikes on civilians in
denes the implications we've got
politics being played with Western
support for Ukraine for international
funding going forward and then there
were two I am today suspending my
campaign why could now be a slam dunk
for Trump even with his mental Fitness
in question and Canadian democracy in
the hands of gen Z we say to ourselves
really can the government do very much
what will it take to get them to
vote GL National with forign Asser
reporting tonight Colleen Christie good
evening thanks for joining us Israel is
escalating its attacks tonight with the
torment in Gaza growing for civilians as
the conflict between Israel and Hamas
rages on the number of Palestinians
killed keeps piling up according to
gaza's Hamas run Health Ministry more
than 25,000 Palestinians have died since
the War Began and more than 62,000 have
been wounded each day more and more
innocent lives are lost the United
Nations Chief says the Bloodshed is
heartbreaking and Israel's military
operations have spread mass destruction
the level of death Despair and
displacement is unprecedented and with
Israel appearing far from achieving its
goal of eliminating Hamas and freeing
more than 100 hostages there's no end in
sight to the fighting McKenzie gray has
our top story tonight and a warning it
contains graphic
images
the call to prayer over
Gaza interrupted by Israeli air strikes
are now daily occurrence across the
territory those attacks pushing 85% of
their population out of their homes
according to the United Nations and into
refugee camps like this one we're
getting the basics is nearly impossible
this mother desperately scrambling to
find antibiotics to treat her child's
lung
infection children will suffer until
they die she says if there's no
treatment this is a slow death similar
health concerns in the Central City of
Della where garbage is piled up for a
month and a half food for the goats and
dogs that's unlikely to be cleaned up
soon the mayor a member of Hamas
admitting before the war they couldn't
provide proper services and there's no
chance they'll be able to
now his city has been a constant Target
of bombing attacks across the territory
have now killed more than 25,000 th000
people according to the Hamas run Health
Ministry but the Israeli Defense Forces
have been increasingly looking outside
of Gaza for targets including these two
positions against Hezbollah in Lebanon a
concerting trend for the United Nations
we must do all we can to prevent
spillover of this conflict across the
region Antonio Gutierrez also
criticizing Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu for his repeated
rejections of a two-state solution which
continues to ruffle feathers with
Western allies I think it's very
disappointing uh that Benjamin Nar who
has uh said that it's not in some senses
a surprise he's spent his entire
political career against a two-state
solution a career that's coming under
increasing pressure domestically as
Netanyahu has been unable to secure the
release of over a 100 hostages held by
Hamas we're here to tell them that we're
done with them and we want elections and
we want to choose a new government it's
not just the UK Canada has also push
back against netanyahu's rejection of a
two-state solution with the Prime
Minister saying Colleen it's the only
way forward for the region McKenzie gray
in Ottawa thanks McKenzie it's been
almost two years since Russia launched
its fullscale invasion of Ukraine a war
that also shows no signs of letting up
and now questions over who's responsible
for a deadly blast in Russian controll
detet at least 27 people died when a
busy Market was shelled Russia's foreign
Ministry calls it a barbaric Act of
terrorism against civilians we cannot
verify Russia's claims and Ukraine is
yet to comment a Redmond Shannon has
more and another warning some of you may
find the images in this story
disturbing it was 10:00 a.m. on Sunday
when the shelling struck this
Marketplace in the outskirts of donet
City the husband of one victim said he
got a call from his wife's phone it was
someone else telling him she was
dead traded at the market right here
when I arrived she was still warm but
she's gone the russian-backed governor
of DK region says Ukraine is to blame
keev has not
commented but in a video statement
Ukrainian president vlodimir zalinski
said Russia shelled more than a 100
locations in Ukraine on Sunday alone
Russia's foreign Ministry called the
donet attack a barbaric Act of terrorism
by Ukraine and said it was done with the
use of weapons supplied by the
West donet is close to the front lines
but has effectively been under moscow's
control since it was seized by
russian-backed separatists a decade ago
thousands died in the region in the
years after 2014 but since moscow's 2022
Invasion the vast majority of Civilian
deaths in Ukraine have been caused by
Russian attacks you'll need to be
established you know where the shelling
came from and the question is you know
was this a shell intended for a military
Target was it part of the crossfire on
the front lines with the Russians if it
is shown Ukrainian shells from the West
killed these people it may hinder
zelinsky's pleas for more military aid
we've got politics being played by
Republicans in the United States but I
don't think they'll use this incident
they they're blackmailing Aid to Ukraine
because they want to get Draconian
measures on border security passed also
on Sunday a suspected Ukrainian drone
attack at this gas export facility near
Russia's second largest city of St
Petersburg it's a, kilometers from
Ukraine and the second such attack
attempted in that region in the past
week Redmond Channon Global News
London hundreds of thousands of people
are gathering across Germany to protest
a right-wing political party known as
the
afd organizers estimate around 350,000
people took part in in a demonstration
in Berlin today similar demonstrations
were held across the country all weekend
protests have gained momentum after
reports emerged afd party members
attended meetings with neo-nazis and
other extremists to discuss the mass
deportation of migrants Asylum Seekers
and some German citizens of foreign
origin the party has been soaring in
opinion polls months ahead of three
major regional
elections in the US there's been a major
shakeup in the 2024 presidential
election campaign Florida Governor Ronda
santis once thought to be a major
Contender for the Republican nomination
officially ended his campaign today I
can't ask our supporters to volunteer
their time and donate their resources if
we don't have a clear path to Victory
it's clear to me that a majority of
Republican primary voters want to give
Donald Trump another chance the
announcement comes just days before
voters in New Hampshire hold their
primary on Tuesday which is now just a 2
race between Nikki Haley and front
runner Donald Trump Jackson prco is in
Manchester New Hampshire with more
Jackson Colleen this stunning
development happened just hours before
Ronda santis was set to meet with his
supporters here in New Hampshire his
exit from the campaign now means that
Nikki Haley is the only person in
position to possibly stop Donald
Trump the former un Ambassador is
polling closer to Trump here than she
was in Iowa but is still backed by
double digits according to the latest
surveys Trump is hoping a blowout result
will effectively wrap up this campaign
before it goes any further and tonight
he has the endorsement of Ronda santis
on his side Haley though is hoping for a
shocking performance to really upset
this race and send a message that voters
want an alternative to Trump she has
become more aggressive in her attacks on
the front runner this weekend
questioning his mental Fitness after a
high-profile Gaff on Friday in which
Trump repeatedly confused Haley with
Nancy Pelosi while talking about the
January 6th attack Nikki Haley is in
charge of security we offered her 10,000
people soldiers National Guard so
whatever they want they turned it down
these things happen because the more you
age it just does you're you have decline
look at Joe Biden he's totally different
now than he was two years ago that's a
fact it's what happens now this primary
is also unusual for Democrats President
Joe Biden isn't on the ballot here
because Democrats moved their first
primary to South Carolina in February
but New Hampshire is still defiantly
holding theirs this Tuesday so there's
now a right-in campaign for Biden and
there's another Factor at play here a
push amongst Democrats to register as
Republicans at least temporarily so they
can vote for Haley and deliver some sort
of upset to Donald Trump all of these
moving Parts make this primary one to
really watch closely especially because
of the large number of independent
voters in this state who can deliver a
last minute surprise not unlike the one
we just saw today Colleen Jackson prco
in New Hampshire thanks Jackson prime
minister Justin Trudeau and his
ministers are in Montreal for a retreat
to firm up their agenda before
Parliament is back in session in a few
weeks affordability housing and
immigration just some of the topics the
liberal cabinet will be focusing on in
the coming days Abigail Bean has more
from Montreal
Abigail ministers gathered here in
Montreal late Sunday afternoon kicking
things off with a working dinner the big
focus on the agenda affordability
everything around the cost of living
will be discussed over the next few days
that includes housing challenges grocery
prices and child care it's the big topic
of conversation among Canadians with so
many struggling with inflation and high
prices it's also what the opposition is
focused on as they Hammer the government
about a lack of action on these files
and will continue to focus on when the
house returns at the end of January the
Liberals have been trailing in the polls
for month months and this is an
opportunity to reset refocus and see if
they can win back some of that middle
class that has always been so prominent
in their messaging Liberals are trying
to make the argument that they're taking
action quickly especially on housing
government sources highlighting to
Global News the nearly two dozen housing
agreements that have been signed since
the last cabinet retreat in PEI in the
summer but obviously there's no quick
fix to that problem you can't build
homes overnight a complicated
intersection in files here comes with
immigration with the government
considering a cap on International
students and further down the agenda a
focus on Canada US relations the
Canadian ambassador to the US is one of
the special guests addressing cabinet on
that file common in a US election year
the government needs to plan for every
outcome bracing for the possibility of a
second Donald Trump Administration a big
question here is whether we'll see
anything significant announced
especially on housing or immigration the
cabinet Retreat continues until Tuesday
Abigail ban global news Montreal
as liberal cabinet ministers Gather in
Montreal one demographic politicians
can't afford to overlook his young
voters people born in 1997 or later are
considered part of Generation Z or Zed
unholsters say they're engaging in
politics in different ways than older
Generations our chief political
correspondent David Aken explains let's
restart in the House of Commons the
Prime Minister takes his seat I would
invite the right honorable prime
minister to address the house the pm
today is 21-year-old Russell van raly
thank you so much uh Mr Speaker he is
one of about a 100 students from Queens
University in Kingston Ontario eager to
learn more about politics by
participating in this case in the
school's annual model Parliament this
group will be among the 4 and A5 million
Canadians under the age of 30 eligible
to vote in the next general election
that's close to 15% of the electorate
demographers call most in this group
generation Zed I think my generation has
a little bit more of a cynical approach
to thinking about how politicians are
going to be helping us out right now I
think we look at the housing crisis um
and the environment we say to ourselves
really can the government do very much
van raly and many in this room say they
voted federally for the first time in
2021 but they would be in the minority
among their gen Zed peers this chart
shows voter turnout rates for young
people that's the blue line versus voter
turnout rates for all other people
that's the orange line over the last
seven Federal elections and in each one
the story is the same people aged 18 to
24 just don't turn out at the same rates
as older people in fact in the 2021
general election just
46% of young people showed up to vote
versus 62% of all other voters pollsters
around the world say when generation Zed
does show up at the polls they are more
likely to vote for a progressive party
like the NDP but that is not a given for
me it's actually always been an issues
based um engagement with politics I
think a lot of the political issues I
care about I would like to see par like
participation and collaboration across
party lines the key takeaway for
political parties about this cohort of
Voters this generation Zed is that they
are much more likely than older voters
to move their vote back and forth across
the political Spectrum depending on
which party is working best on the
issues that are their priorities and
those priorities right now climate
change and housing David Aken Global
News
Ottawa what's that smell coming up the
mysterious foul odor across Vancouver
and a rare winter air quality statement
in
Calgary and the major storm prompting
weather warnings and creating Havoc
across the
UK the city of Vancouver issued an
unusual advisory today after a strong
odor blanketed the region residents
across Vancouver and neighboring bernabe
woke up this morning to a strange
burning smell firefighters track the
scent to a refinery in Burnaby fire
crews are calling it an industrial
incident but say there's no immediate
safety concern still residents were
advised to close their windows and air
intakes a special air quality statement
has been issued for Calgary Environment
Canada says stagnant winter weather
conditions have trapped pollution close
to the ground creating a haze over the
city it's expected to stick around until
stronger winds and warmer temperatures
move in sometime this week Indonesia's
most active volcano is erupting forcing
thousands to
[Music]
flee searing gas clouds spread and lava
flows down the slopes of Mount marapi on
the world's most populated island of
java several other volcanoes across
Indonesia also erupted this weekend
forcing
evacuations she's up she's down she's
gone planes struggled to land at
London's Heathrow Airport today as a
major storm blew in weather warnings
were issued across the UK with wind
gusts reaching close to 130 km an hour
in some regions forecasters are warning
residents to expect power outages flying
debris and travel disruptions through
Monday ahead the growing Trend aimed at
preventing tenant Ren evictions across
the
country amid a housing crisis losing
your homes to the landlord can renovate
and Hike the rent is a frightening
Prospect laws to prevent Ren evictions
have been on the books in BC and other
markets for a number of years now as
Shan prevel reports Hamilton Ontario is
joining the trend
possibly being homeless Ling looming
over your head is is is a stressful
thing EV pedit of Hamilton is facing
eviction as the owners of his sixplex
want to renovate the building and while
he can get assistance from the Ontario
Disability support program for shelter
it's only close to
$900 there's nowhere around that you
could get a place for even half that we
could be out on the street his story
isn't new with stories of rovics from
coast to coast Hil is trying to stop bad
faith Renovations with a new bylaw
requiring landlords to obtain a special
permit before ending a tency to renovate
a unit it's a move Alejandra Ruiz Vargas
with Acorn Canada says is a big win now
we have hope the idea that now we are
protected then now we Are Not Invisible
rules around renov evictions vary across
Canada places like Ontario and Quebec
for example require tenants to be given
First Choice to return housing expert
Brian ducet says that doesn't always
happen even if landlords could face
fines for not doing so so it's not
uncommon for a tenant to be living in a
place the landlord renovi them does some
basic cosmetic work and the rent jumps
the Hamilton bylaw will also see
landlords have to make arrangements for
a tenant who wants to return and this
could include providing temporary
accommodations more cities are
considering similar bylaws and Advocates
say that could prompt higher levels of
government to take action amid a
national housing shortage that shows few
signs of ending the province has the
power to amend the res idal tenes act
and completely rethink how Renovations
are dealt with I believe that is a good
leverage for Canadians for tenants
across the country to have these two
cities pedit is not sure if Hamilton's
bylaw will help his case but is hopeful
for Canadians in the long run hopefully
it'll stop predatory landlords um from
displacing tenants for for the sole
purpose of raising rent Sean preville
Global
News next graphic images a West Coast
first nation's modern take on sharing
history and
[Music]
traditions there are countless ways to
pass down your heritage and in BC One
first nation is innovating three members
are working on a graphic novel to
Showcase traditional knowledge and
culture safia Pani spoke to one of the
homco first nation artists about how
they're bringing their stories to life
we have the narrator Raven explaining
that this is the boat's first time on
the water and the youngest member of the
family's first time going clamming
bringing history to life through
illustrations we're just kind of like
using our imagination like using our
experience going out to these locations
and like seeing what we saw and making
our imagery based on that Valen enstein
is one of three indigenous artists
working with the hco first nation in
Campbell River to create a graphic novel
about traditional knowledge and stories
all based off recordings by the elders
in the early '90s which were then
produced into podcasts to help enhance
their experience the artists visited the
First Nation back in November that's I
mean that's how my process has been is
very much like trying to make a love
letter to what I got to learn and be
involved in and what the elders talked
about in their youth the heroes in these
stories canoe across the water to gather
food and climb giant mountains to H
and children reading these stories are
sure to be inspired along the way the
cultural preservation part of it like
even in like a pop culture way like it
keeps youth able to like be connected to
these things and to know what like their
histories are what their Heritage is
like it's given an opportunity to
further preserve the language and the
culture which is so important right um
and you know for youth you know they're
constantly evolving on how they gather
their news their information and how
they learn about our traditions and for
onstein being able to give back to his
community is the most meaningful part I
have memories of being you know the
young indigenous kid and like seeing
native people in comics for the first
time in my life that really honestly
blew my mind it it must be such a good
feeling it's a really good feeling yeah
Sophia Pani Global
News and that is global national for
this Sunday night I'm Colleen
Christie
[Applause]
tonight's your Canada is ottawa's R
Canal Skateway which finally opened to
the public today it's the first time in
nearly two years skaters are being
allowed back on the ice after a warmer
than usual winter last year kept at
closed the entire season such an iconic
Canadian experience thanks for watching
Donna will be back with you tomorrow
have a great
night